Salam alaikum peace be unto you how are
you sure guys the time they let her bill
out I mean how are you Eddie good at
hamdulillah it's nice to be with you
again after all this long intermission
it seems like forever it's been a while
but I'm really excited that you're back
here on the Deen show yeah it's nice to
be with you as we introduce you in the
opening this is a shake east of Estes
who has his own section at the Deen show
calm he's the founder president of guide
us TV oh yeah here in America and it's
viewed in Canada and the US and you can
catch it at goddess tv.com yeah of
course that'll go all over the world if
you go that route yeah
but for as far as the satellites go we
do have Canada United States both yes
masha'Allah we're gonna be talking about
today you know one of the most important
topics important things in our life is
establishing a relationship with the one
who creditors trying to live that life
that's pleasing to the crater but many
of us we get caught up into into the
day-to-day activity so we want to give
our viewing audience and the audience
that's here's some tips on how we can go
away from making the conversation just
baseball basketball many people don't
feel they are qualified to talk about
Islam but and they feel that how can I
break the ice yeah or it did some feel
that's not an obligation to open their
mouth and to invite people to have a
relationship with the one who created
them so let's talk about that point how
can we break the ice and get people that
are motivated to open up a conversation
and to invite them to what will give
them peace Islam well naturally the
first thing I always look at and as you
will know is that Tamala G of words
because the more I understand the words
and more I understand what people are
trying to tell me in Islam we do have
something that's more than just a
relationship with Almighty Allah we have
something called the connection in
Arabic language there's the word Silla
Silla means to connect to something and
we have from that toward salat and Salam
obviously is our connection with Allah
that we make five times a day but when
we talk about our connection with the
people or a relationship with the people
then we have another subject
and this is our Dawa and Dawa this
related to another word Dora and dries
to call on a law and DA is what we do
all the time or what people call prey so
Silla is connection with the law but
Dharana is calling upon the law now
let's bring it to they're subject to the
people the dawa calling the people to
the way of a law to call them back to
the worship of the one guy which you're
always talking about in every show I
never heard you open any choice except
you always mentioned the creation the
Creator the relationship is always you
said that as the format for every show
you've ever done I think I don't I
didn't miss any but I think that I've
seen that in every single show so people
should know just when they opened up the
program and started watching you're
serious you're talking about one God
worship him on his terms
well essentially that is what we're
always trying to do but how can we help
our brothers and sisters have a better
understanding and you already mentioned
that a lot of times we're kind of
nervous with the people we don't know
where to go
they're not Muslim we don't know what to
say how's the weather weather's nice
well it's kind of cold it's windy it's
who cares you know I'm not a weatherman
I'm joking about that well how about the
big game okay well let's talk about the
game and that was a three point spread
was it wait a minute I'm not a
sportscaster either you know so why am I
getting into these subjects and usually
it's because people are nervous when
they meet each other and they want to
find a common ground so I like the idea
again going back to the main show the
things that are stressed again and again
our common ground is to go to the
subject of the creator and there is only
one creator he created everything now
what are there a Hindu or a Buddhist a
Jew a Christian or even some Muslims are
kind of straight far away you know they
still know there's a creator there's
something behind everything that
happened but if a guy gets hung up on
that and he doesn't want to go forward
then what do you do you know there's a
quite a bit of atheism now because so
many people are seeing the fallacies of
these made-up religions and so they
assume that all religions are the same
so there are a number of issues
we can pick up on for instance I was
talking with some of our brothers the
other day and I said that you know if we
do that tomorrow of words and look at
words they give you something to talk
about for instance somebody said he is
from Palestine and I said to him why do
you say Palestine me so what do you mean
I said well you know and I know in
Arabic it's called Philistine and in the
Bible it's called Philistine who came up
with this word Palestine so why don't
you use the word that you know that what
we say in Arabic he said well then
people won't know I said no they don't
you learn real quick if they say where
is that look what the opportunity if you
said I'm from Philistine this is just an
example but then he says oh well where
is that well it's in the Bible that's
where it is you know about the
Philistines uh not exactly sure you
remember when David threw the rock and
killed Goliath he was the Philistine and
after that what happened so you have to
realize that the Philistines lost the
battle to who the followers of David and
what was the religion of David ah now
you get to open up the subject the same
would be true if you want to go to the
New Testament
for instance if somebody's talking about
Jerusalem again that's Philistine right
but Jerusalem what is Jerusalem at the
Monty the word jar rule Salaam later
they pronounced this word so them as
Shalom but originally even the Jewish
pronounced it Salaam Jerusalem and what
is that well in Arabic you say dar in
the old hebrew they said jar Darussalam
what is that
place the peace so if you think about it
by the way we have schools and massagin
mosques in United States called dar
Salam
that's the peace so if you said Jarrah
sent them and they're gone was that
that's Jerusalem you believe in
Jerusalem
oh yeah okay there you are a place of
peace of course it's been anything but
that for the past many centuries
beside the point the point we're trying
to stress is that common
D that we can come to that we can talk
about so people can see and understand
where we're coming from
because once we establish Jerusalem
Jerusalem base of peace this is where
Who Lived did Jesus live there oh and
after Jesus what religion did those
people follow because some of them
continued to follow Judaism as was
understood by Moses but at that stage
they are Jewish no longer believe
incorrectly because Jesus has come with
the message to clarify and they didn't
accept it
average Christian will say that's right
so those people are no longer on the
right religion likewise at the time of
Moses when Moses came that is Salam and
he talked to his people they were all
the sons and daughters of who Abraham so
the flowers of Abrahamic faith when
Moses came he clarified and brought
clear Commandments for them and if you
didn't follow those and you're not a
follower the true religion anymore then
if you come to Jesus and you said okay
anybody not following Jesus now it
doesn't matter what he believed about
David or Moses or ever had
it's Jesus and from you don't believe
him then where are you
likewise the last and the final
messenger from the same Abrahamic chain
through Ishmael who is Muhammad
sallallahu wasallam whoever knows about
this message of the unity of God the
oneness of Almighty Allah and they went
to worship him on his terms following
His commandments
obeying him then they need to be a
follower of all of these prophets and
always ending with the last prophet in
this case would be mom give us some tips
you're in a plane a train or an
automobile and you have a few minutes
you got to break the ice and you want to
go ahead and leave them with something
to think about to contemplate about the
purpose of life how in your experience
have you did it and give us and our
viewing audience some of these secret
tips I don't know if it's a secret tip I
think it's a forgotten T forgotten -
yeah I do it I believe is a forgotten to
it because everything from the problems
not
secret we're just kind of dumb we don't
pay attention but here's a tip before I
get in the airplane before I get the bus
before I'm in the public talking with
the people I've already done my work my
homework really literally homework
what's my homework at home at night in
the middle of the night get up get out
of bed make although if you have trouble
getting up in the night just drink a
bunch of water before you go to sleep
oops and you'll get up I haven't left
there our studio audience is laughing
but you know it will work you get up and
then after you make your will ooh face
the camera and pray to Allah spawn
toilet rec attain to Raqqa and then one
by itself which is called which and then
when your heads on the ground just cry
to Allah and ask him let me share this
message the way you want to share it
with the people help me along help me
and I guarantee it has happened to me
every single time something good happen
to me the very next day some way or
another I benefited somebody else
benefited but together mutually
everybody benefits now when somebody
comes to me I used to be looking for
these secret tips okay which as I just
said there's no such thing but in that I
would think what I'll say this I'll say
that okay Oh sir did you know that if
you don't believe in uh no you're gonna
go to hell or you know that sound like
the old Christian that sales pitch do
you believe in Jesus you know you don't
believe in Jesus all right
okay well we don't really have that in
fact I've seen it happen that I sit down
in the airplane and I'm just looking
through something that they got there
and somebody let me say excuse me
how come you wearing that thing on your
hair are you Jewish one time a lady in
the security line you know when you go
through for the so called security check
I call it insecurity because everybody
feels insecure but as you're going
through this thing you know here's this
lady old lady she looks at me she sees
how hungry she goes um what are you poor
little old lady she's scared you know I
said I'm a chaplain Oh
okay we went a little further than
Alliance should turn around she said
what's a chaplain as long as that wasn't
a Muslim she was okay but when people
begin to open up and say something to me
that's when I really want to be prepared
I don't think that it's a really a big
benefit just to talk about the ways to
open a conversation just like to walk up
to somebody and say by the way just you
know that Islam is of s is going to
religion United States I mean that could
add to their phobia that they already
have and you might even find them coming
back at some weird things and you
wouldn't be prepared for it
so if they see you as a Muslim or it's
suspect you might be one of those at
least he gives you a place to open up I
use the words because of course English
was my forte I spent a lot of time
studying English language and I enjoyed
that I any language really mother
Spanish Arabic English but when we come
to the subject of the person themselves
then I look at the person as though I'm
from them I got to get it from them I
need to know it when I do it Jew my foot
but for instance a lot of times they'll
ask me what's the juma collective going
to be about I say about 20 minutes by
the way if you laugh a little louder you
don't have microphones than we do anyway
we don't often have a studio audience
but anyway to come back to that when I
look at the people in the juma and the
mustard and I'm I'm thinking what is
today's topic well if I look in there
all Arabs it's gonna have to have a lot
of Arabic in it but I'm looking at
they're all use I needed to think in
terms of what they're interested in I
need to bring it down to where we can
all be on a common ground and that's the
same thing if you're talking to a
housewife about space travel or
something should be like who and at the
same time you're talking about a guy
that's a computer geek everyone's
talking about megabytes you let's talk
about you know how much
Ram that you get different things like
that so put it in perspective you got to
think who you're talking to
and sometimes you don't need to be a
conversationalist you don't need to be a
lecturer all you need to do is having
some basic knowledge answer a few
questions
how come you Muslims have to kill all
the Jews and Christians well I don't
really think we have to because I never
heard anybody tell me that well I saw on
TV I saw on the internet my pastor said
well you know it's good thing that God
led you to somebody that lives that life
because we really don't know I'm not
calling your pastor a liar not saying
that media would prevaricate and I'm not
trying to indicate to you that the
Internet's not the best place to get
information but as a matter of fact we
Muslims are ordered to be the best to
the Jews and Christians so that's really
the opposite of what you heard and in
fact Allah said in the Quran the Jews
and the Christians from them are the
closest to us in belief and certainly we
give the highest respect to everybody
but especially those who are closest to
assembly couple more questions before we
come to a close tell us sheikh Dawa
given the invitation to the purpose of
life is this something that is
restricted to the Imams
to the people of knowledge or is this an
obligation for every Muslim well I want
to give credit to our Imams and our
teachers of Islam and mention that it's
their responsibility to teach us how to
do the Dower know Dallas and to give us
some evidence and proofs for what it is
we're doing in the dollar they should be
active with us in helping us in sharing
the message but then after that we each
and every one of us are responsible to
do whatever it is that we know our
prophets of life Solomon said this in a
way that's very clear
he said convey from me even if it's only
one ayah and with that I mentioned a
couple of things you might be surprised
to know that one ayah no we're going to
talk about one verse of the Quran right
one is there a single Muslim you know
that doesn't know bismillah ar-rahman
ar-rahim every single Muslim knows
business is that right guys yeah don't
know in your head the TV
see you what do you say all right now
bismillah means in the name of allah
ar-rahman ar-rahim the gracious the most
merciful etc so if you know that convey
that and you might say well I don't know
what that's gonna mean watch in
Baltimore Maryland a couple years back
in Ramadan I met her brother there who
told me he came to Islam from that I
said what he said okay I was a Christian
14 years ago I became a Jew or that
didn't impress me yet he's like wait me
went backward he said no because in
Christianity there were too many
controversies there's too much contrast
between Old Testament New Testament and
so many things he said so I went and to
the Jewish and became a Jew studied it
learned Hebrew with the Hebrew and the
experience with the rabbi's he came to
know that it was unknown to them what
God's name really was and you're not
supposed to even attempt to pronounce
the Tetra nomogram which yeah i hope i
pronounced it right but what that
represents is the actual name of god and
even the rabbi's that i know will never
pronounce it and even one time I said is
it Allah they said we're not allowed to
even speculate we won't even send them
and they refused to say Allah by the way
so he argued with him he says fourteen
years he's put into this thing talking
about they said we don't really know
what's the name of God and he's thinking
how could I be in a religion believing
in a God that we don't even know the
name of until one day some brothers
print playing sports had put that four
on down on a bench somewhere and he
looked down and he said hey guys was
this and they come over what you're
talking about he said right there in
English in the name of God the most
gracious the most merciful I said do you
know what's God's name is that what this
means
I said yeah everybody knows it's all
he said what it says in the name of God
what's God's name he said well in Arabic
it says
bismillah in the name of Allah we
translated it as God he said his name is
Allah they said yeah you know that yeah
it comes from Allah and that's a god but
Allah
it means the one and only God that's his
actual name that's one of the s mom was
surprised of Allah they begin to much as
my was available of his names his
characteristics his attributes he is the
epitome for instance of suburb which is
the ultimate patients or persevering he
is s-salam he is the peace from him
comes peace there is no peace it except
it has to come from the peace he is the
peace the more they talked about their
brothers just standing on her I said
well a little Arshad Mohammed or so long
he entered Islam with that and when I
met him he said I'm learning Arabic now
I want to be a Muslim my wife who also
converted to Judaism has now converted
her with him over to Islam their
children now are in Islam and they're
doing great that's from one ayah another
ayah right after that al hamdulillah of
Bill al-amin how many people know
alhamdulillah bill out of me huh I met a
guy who came to slam from this iron and
how that came about where he was thrown
with some of his friends he'd known him
for a long time they said they weren't
even good Muslims they don't even you
know many things he said about him but
the bottom line he also saw something in
a book that somebody had and it says
hummed a lot of Bilal Amin and then
English translation says all the praises
due to the Lord of the Worlds with an S
what I emphasize it he said that all of
his life he said if there really was a
god he left Christianity he said because
they have no provision for anything
outside of some God that's the God of
Abraham and Moses but what about being
the God of the entire earth what about
being the god of the moon and the god of
the Sun and they got and they don't have
any answers
so that's fake worship that's polytheism
idolatry don't mention the moon don't
mention the stars so when he sees this
and he's asking the brother but it said
worlds he said yeah
although it's the Lord of the Worlds any
life that's there regardless of its on
earth or in outer space and people that
we don't see said people who don't see
what are you talking about said the
djinn he started explaining about the
gym the guys like you believe it now of
course he said I've always wondered if
there was even another level of people
or beings or or ghosts or some kind of
demons or something and they said yeah
we know all about it
Islam he said oh my god and this
provides what he said yeah he said a
shadow a lie let alone someone worse off
he said that brought him to Islam and
then he studied and learned a lot more
about the details of the jinn and I'm
the things they do the difference
between angels and Jen the devil is not
an angel etc things that there's a lot
of evidence for in common sense and he
said I'm the happiest guy in the world
because of that one verse so again we'll
go back to whatever source and I'm said
convey it from me even if it's a single
verse in the last couple minutes that we
have we're about to close for those of
our brothers in humanity who are tuning
in for the first time and they like what
we're talking about and they're also
confused in the chaos that's out there
and they want to know the truth in the
last few minutes that we have can you
express to them what is the call what is
the invitation to well the invitation of
course is to be your house for dinner
well let's go to your house for dinner
we're in Chicago and you're the likely
one to be the host here let's do this
when I'm wrapping things up with people
you said it right we only got a few
minutes with somebody and then they're
gone
oh and I wanted to say this I wanted to
say that why didn't I oh man I forgot
this i forgot to tell them oh this is
why we developed websites i have 2200
websites for islam and they're very
simple to deal with most of them you
it's easy to memorize because there
they are what it says for instance just
ask Islam is where you can ask questions
search for Islam that's where you can
search for the topic you want and these
are all coms another one that you can go
do it very simple you want to know about
God or law even if you forget my website
just put God space Allah in Google and
it'll be the first one pop-up all the
rest of them by the way you're gonna
attack Islam but at least you'll
remember ours is God Allah calm after
that prophet of islam calm science islam
that's for the atheist dot-com and then
when you get all done with this long
list it slams women calm about jihad
calm links to islam calm etc etc then
you say oh i should have wrote them all
down well the last one i said is the
only one you really need to know links
to islam calm and you can find these
links and go over it because what we're
gonna say on your show there'll be a few
highlights but nobody remembers
everything i won't even remember it
tomorrow what all the videos you and i
just talked about but if i have a
reference point and i think that's more
important than trying to be a great
speaker or articulate and what i'm
talking about
just let them have their own reference
point on their own they go to the
internet they type in something when
they're comfortable relaxed in their
home and they can sit there take their
time drink their coffee answer the phone
it's right in front of them and they say
you know what that's what i believe this
is what it's all about I too want to
join this and I want to worship my
creator on his terms his way and I want
to be one of those guys that does it and
of course we know that slightly a little
long mama the person who's not that
tech-savvy we just have I want to really
take advantage of the last couple minute
almost that we have the person that is
not tech savvy they don't use the
internet and we got their attention what
advice do you give them I'd ask him
where did you see the Dean show it's on
the Internet hello there in somebody's
house someone brought them over they
were drinking some cheesy innocent
Brioni and now
we might never turn back oh boy all
right if if they know how to turn on a
TV set they can watch us on satellite on
guide us TV if they don't know how to
turn on TV set ask an eight-year-old to
come turn the computer on cuz they all
know how to do that and go to the Dean
shows up put the words in front ehe Dean
show com are put in guide us DB and
watch us there
Thank You say thank you so much for
being with me buddy the Creator a lot of
wood and you Monica we'll be right back
what is close to death that's all God
don't let me die but he's got something
better than this world what's God going
to get out of punishing you anyway you
have to connect to this understanding
that the Quran is from God that Muhammad
is His Messenger and the answers to the
problems in our life are there and if
we're gonna worship something I figured
I might as well worship the Creator
instead of any of the creations
I'm not a standalone if a box by my side
I am not afraid to stand alone I am not
afraid to stand alone I am Not Afraid
we're taking some questions from our
live studio audience and the sister who
asked the question what are the things
to emphasize about Islam when you only
have a little bit of time shape one of
the first things that I try to remember
is that tell heed the oneness of God is
the thing that all the scholars told us
to work on that don't get into a lot of
other things like somebody who might
even say like why do you cut off
people's hands well I never cut
anybody's hand off in my life I've never
even seen it done I don't even know what
that's all about really because they
said what I read on the internet you
chop off people's hands well I got both
hands everybody I know he's got both
hands so I don't know what if you're a
thief or you they cut off your hand I
said well you know the only person
should worry but that's a thief or you a
thief what's your problem so then they
start laughing and think about it you
know and then but we'll go to this you
see the same Creator the heavens the
earth they sent a message to the people
again and again and again and people
play with it corrupted do things to it
so that's why more messengers come to
more people because God never punishes
the people unless he sent a messenger to
them and the message is always the same
worship God without partners no images
no idols don't try to represent God with
anything that exists in the creation
because he is the creator
simple as that here on the D show with
president Shaykh Yusuf esta the man
formerly guide US TV former man of the
cloth you call it man of the cloth yeah
preacher Minister Islam way back and we
are taking questions from our live
studio audience and the question is
about the Dajjal well first of all I
don't say man in the cloth because there
really wasn't a pastor of a church the
most of the closest I came was when I
was a music minister but preaching the
word was always something near and dear
to me are you scared my Bible everywhere
I went and put it into practice not just
on Sunday but if I pick up a stranger or
give him a ride or something I want to
preach to him by the way that's the same
thing up indeed I used to do as a Muslim
a lot of people that they're at IPC I in
Africa right now they originally got
this lamp through him giving them a ride
Marshall I'll give you an idea you can
help people out along the way and then
tell them about Islam but anyway to come
back to this subject now that as far as
the Dajjal is concerned this is what we
call the Antichrist Dajjal he's the liar
he is Messiah Dajjal which is the false
Christ missing is like Messiah or Christ
and Messiah Dajjal he is clearly
mentioned in hadith so sister what you
want to do is go to search for Islam
type in either Antichrist or Bijal with
two J's and then it'll bring you all of
this but for sure it will look like a
human he will talk like a human he has
human features the unusual
characteristics about him are basically
his eyes he has one eye that's a bulb
it's like a like a grape another eye
he's blind and it totally he sees out of
one eye and he doesn't see out of the
other eye and that's that's very clear
but he will do miracles and make people
think he's Jesus come back again that's
why he's called Messiah Dajjal so it's
not the television some people said it's
the one-eyed God but I heard that from
the Christians in the 1950s do you
believe it or not they were saying
that's the Dajjal right there or the
Antichrist because it brings so much
trash and garbage in our house not like
now when it's only nice stuff that we
have on TV anyway other signs that you
can find out about this there will be
great trials and tribulations that will
be taking place and it is not yet that
has not come somebody said that Jesus is
back on earth walking around hiding so
that the people won't kill him that's
also not true it's clear and hadith that
he will come was angels to angels and he
will come down from heaven and he will
and in a place in Damascus Syria that's
where he will be and it would be time
for the Salah so these things have not
happened I don't care what other things
they try to relate to it political
scenes economic problems technology and
all the rest of it it's not true as
simple as that your common sense we read
the hadith this is not right continue
with the question about the imam mahdi a
lot of people ask about that well again
this is from hadith this is not
mentioned in Quran so you have to know
hadith you go to the hadith it and find
out you can go to our web site search
for slap calm tripe in Maddie's spell it
mah di Maddie and then you'll find out
about it know what we know is the
promise of Salaam told us that the Mahdi
will come he will come before Lisa
Alex Ram comes the fact that he has not
come yet his clear proof that Jesus is
not on earth walking around even though
some big famous person said it I'm not
going to say his name because you know
we love him for the sake of my love we
hope Allah guide him but in any case
coming back to the subject of the Mandi
he is going to be Imam Mahdi that's true
and he's not gonna have magical powers
anything like that he does not know he's
the Madi and dill he is the Mahdi you
got that he's not gonna be walking
around as a kid saying I'm the Mandi
that also you saw it on YouTube maybe
was some people of a different sect of
Islam I'm not gonna say what but they
came up with this idea it's not true
because the hadith is very clear that
when he comes
his name is going to be a clue for you
his name is gonna be Muhammad even of
the law he said his name will be my name
in his father's name will be my father's
name that is Muhammad even of the law
and for sure that is one clue but then
the other thing is he has to be from the
progeny of Prophet Muhammad SAW Islam
and there is no progeny coming from the
Prophet saws none except by Fatimah and
Ali so as to be coming from Fatima and
Ali
so there's this would be obvious okay
and it would be Mohammed even
the law along the way you can see that
if you've studied some of the various
sects of Islam you can see why some
people believe we're this and we're that
and this and that and that's where the
mistakes start coming in but for sure it
will all if you live long enough you'll
see that happen we don't know when it's
gonna be and you're not supposed to know
when it's going to be but it will come
soon enough there was somebody else to
the Prophet SAW salaam about these last
days when will they come he said what do
you have prepared for it and that's not
much more important for us to be ready
for that with our good deeds incorrect
belief I want to go back to that by the
way that correct belief is critical to
have the right belief there are pita of
the Salaf assaleh if without that our
pita but we'll never make it
I don't care and and they can call
himself Salafi they can call himself
whatever they want to call himself but
without that correct belief and practice
it won't happen continue on with some
questions for Shaikh use of Estes and
from our studio audience the brother was
asking what's the best way when you're
giving to invitation to leave a good
lasting impression one of the best
things I can think of and you referred
to it earlier in the subject of the
Brioni if you can take them to eat or
offer to take them to eat or do
something nice for them right here in
this world because most of people who
are not Muslim are very attached to the
gifts and things you give in this world
whereas I'm I'm much more impressed
for instance if somebody makes draw for
me and my family I really like it thank
you so much for that but other people
would be like okay thanks for the
prayers I gain money so sometimes if you
give them a little pamphlet or brochure
a little booklet maybe I've even given
people money you know just tell them you
know because they need help a lot of
times people need financial help give
somebody a $10 bill and telling a little
bit about Islam and here's hey well
thank you so much whatever in some way
you know you get chance help somebody
else down the road because even if you
say well they're a beggar I'm not gonna
help them no just don't worry about it
you'll get a reward from Allah do your
best
giving gifts that is definitely
thing to do we had one of our guests dr.
Seville on the show and he mentioned a
life story about a doctor giving gifts
during Christmas and is this something
where it would be acceptable that doctor
as a true story was given gifts of wine
to his friends we're not talking I guess
like this are we and gave away wine wine
yes at Christmas Christmas I can't speak
on the behalf of a Muslim it might do
that but I could tell you that there are
better things to give people than a
headache
I don't I can't I can't wrap my head
around that idea but definitely to be
kind and generous with the people but
not just at Christmas in fact I would
prefer it to be known that when I give
something to somebody that I'm not
trying to tie it into their religion but
I don't want to stop giving things I
don't want to have we're not I'm really
on the subject but some people ask me
about like Mother's Day Father's Day
Easter things like this
I say look if you can be nice to
somebody on one day more so than the
other days you need to work on yourself
to be that level of good every day with
your mom your dad your friends or
whatever it's not about giving a gift on
a birthday because every day that I can
do something good for people I want to
do that so I don't want to I don't want
to say it like just giving something at
a certain time and forget about the wine
hello gifts yeah even then I want to be
sure it's not just a one-shot deal it
should be that whatever I'm doing I
should be continuing it I think our
Prophet SAW salaam and said what means
that our love's what's done continually
even if something small better than
something big but it's only done once
okay so that's it and thank you for
attending this filming